- Okay, welcome, everybody.
I'm Maurice Samuels.
And it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here
this afternoon to the last talk
in this year's Benjamin and
Barbara Zucker lecture series.
Today's speaker David de Jong
is a correspondent in the Middle East
where he writes for the
Dutch Financial Daily,
among other publications.
For the research and writing
of "Nazi Billionaires,"
he reported from Berlin for four years.
Before that de Jong was a
reporter at Bloomberg News
in New York where he
wrote about hidden wealth
and in Amsterdam where he
wrote about European banking
and finance.
His work has also appeared
in the New York Times,
the Wall Street Journal and
Bloomberg Business Week.
De Jong was born and raised in Amsterdam
and currently lives in Tel Aviv.
"Nazi Billionaires" is his first book.
And many of you probably
saw his really fantastic,
hard hitting op-ed in the
New York Times last week.
So hopefully we'll have time
to discuss that as well.
So a word first about how
things will work today,
David will speak for about 40 minutes,
and then we will open it up to
questions from the audience.
Please submit your questions
using the Q&A function
at the bottom of your screen.
We won't be able to see or hear you,
but you can submit questions
at any time during the talk
using the Q&A function, and
I will relay them to David.
So, yeah, so without further ado,
it's really a great
pleasure to see David again,
who I got to know a little
bit in Berlin last year,
and really excited to
hear more about this book,
which I've just been reading.
And I have to say is
just a fantastic read.
In addition to being about, you know,
a completely fascinating subject matter,
it's really well written.
It reads like a novel,
so I highly recommend it to everyone.
All right, now I will
hand it over to David.
- Thank you so much, Maurie,
for that kind introduction,
I am going to be talking
about the families in my book,
who I think, the five families
I write about in my book,
who I think very much,
very well represent,
or their patriarchs at
least very well represent
this kind of, you know,
German big business
or at least an overview
of German big business
because these families were
then and are still today
Germany's most prominent
business dynasties.
And I wanna start it off with,
I'm gonna try and condense
a century from 1919 to 2019
in about 40 minutes.
So I'll be zigzagging
through the five families,
but I'll start off with the
main family, the Quandt dynasty,
whose heirs today control BMW,
at least two of the heirs.
It's still Germany's
wealthiest family today,
and their patriarch Gunther
Quandt loses his wife, Antonia,
in the Spanish flu of 1918.
And in the fall of, pardon
in the spring of 1919,
he takes a night train
from Berlin to Kassel
in the center of Germany,
and he meets a, well,
she's not even a woman yet.
She's a girl, a 17 year old girl
called Magda Friedlander.
Magda Friedlander, who just
came out of a relationship
with a Jewish student
named Chaim Arlozorov
who later becomes a very
well known Zionist in Israel
and is shot dead under very
mysterious circumstances in 1933
on the beach of Tel Aviv.
She comes out of a
relationship with Arlozorov
when she takes that night train in Easter,
in the Easter weekend of 1919,
and she meets Gunther Quandt.
Magda Friedlander is the,
her stepfather is Jewish,
and she's taken on his last name.
Ritschel Friedlander, but
she was baptized Catholic
and raised Catholic, and
she meets Gunter Quandt,
and they go and they, and
Gunther Quandt was 20 years older
than she is, is completely
enamored with her.
And when Magda gets out at
her stop in central Germany
and goes to the boarding
school where she is.
You know, he finds her address,
and he writes to her that very night
when he arrives at his destination,
and he takes her out on a
date and within three dates,
he proposes to her.
Gunther has two sons
from his first marriage.
And he proposes to her, and
she, after long consider,
or after, yeah, some
consideration, she says, yes,
and they get married, or she says, yes,
and they get engaged.
Now, however, to get married,
he has one condition.
Gunther Quandt has one
condition or two conditions,
that she reconverts from
Catholicism back to Protestantism,
which is his, he's Lutheran.
And secondly that she
drops the name Friedlander
before she gets married.
And that she reassumes
her birth name, Ritschel,
which was her biological father's name
because, you know, of course
from his perspective, you know,
he could never get married,
Gunther Quandt could never
get married to a woman
who holds a Jewish last name.
And I think that is very much,
that episode where the book
starts, where my book starts
is very much emblematic for
the thinking of the families
or at least the patriarchs of the families
I'm writing about.
This latent antisemitism,
as opposed to the really
racial antisemitism,
this convinced antisemitism.
These men I write about are not,
they are not convinced antisemites.
They are, you know, for
the most part Protestants
who, you know, very much a
Lutheran theology, you know,
is, you know, from my
view deeply antisemitic.
Also many voters who
voted in the Nazi party,
there was far higher votes for the NSDAP,
in the more Protestant parts of Germany
who saw Hitler really as a
sort of reincarnation to many
of Martin Luther.
So it is really this latent antisemitism
that is prevalent not only in
the circles of big business,
but I would say unfortunately
for the most part
of Christian German society,
both Protestant and Catholic at that time.
Now Gunther Quandt,
who was already from
a very wealthy family,
a textile family, builds up this empire
during the era of hyperinflation
as does his, well, fellow
industrialist, Friedrich Flick,
who ends up being
probably Germany's most
notorious industrialist
of the 20th century and who
is eventually convicted,
the only one in of my main characters,
who's eventually convicted at Nuremberg
for war crimes and
crimes against humanity.
The two of them separately
start very much profiting
from the era of
hyperinflation in the 1920s.
Gunther Quandt manages
through hyperinflation,
which wiped out most
of the middle classes.
But for the speculators of the time,
the stock speculators of the
time was a very profitable era,
managed to take control of a
global battery factory, AFA,
and a global or a weapons factory,
or a weapons firm called DWM.
And that is really the groundwork
of the Quandt business
empire that they see,
that they very much profit
from after Hitler seizes power
in 1933.
Now, as for Friedrich Flick,
he parlays a steel company
that he controls into
a steel conglomerate.
He takes over the United Steelworks
during the hyperinflation era.
And it is very interesting to
see how virulent antisemitism
is already leveled against
kind of the Jewish speculators,
of the great Jewish speculators
of that era in Germany,
where there is this idea of, you know,
they're just speculating.
They're, you know, accumulating stocks,
and they're accumulating
controlling interests
in companies, you know, across the board
of the business spectrum
from industry to textiles
to batteries to weapons.
But these same accusations, you know,
which you still see today
leveled against George Soros,
or the conspiracy theorists do,
you know, you don't see them
leveled against Gunther Quandt
and Friedrich Flick being, you know,
Protestant parts of the
German establishment.
Now I want to go to 1933
and Hitler seizing power
in Germany.
The quickly codifying of
antisemitic laws in Germany,
you quickly see the main,
well, characters in my book
taking advantage of it.
Gunther Quandt gets briefly detained
because at this point
in time, his marriage
to Magda Quandt has dissolved,
and Magda Quandt has on
to become Magda Goebbels.
She divorces Gunther Quandt in 1929
and soon meets Joseph Goebbles
who is then the Reich's,
yeah, the Reich's propaganda
lighter for Berlin,
and is, you know, up and coming
in the then still burgeoning Nazi party.
And they soon become the, you know,
kind of the most prominent
couple of the Third Reich.
And a custody battle ensues.
Gunther Quandt has two sons
from his first marriage,
Herbert and Hellmut, and two,
and has one son together
with Magda called Harald,
called Harald, and a custody
battle about Harald ensues.
And he is arrested,
which he later purports
is on Goebbels's orders.
He's arrested on May 4th, 1933,
three days after Gunther
Quandt becomes a member
of the Nazi party.
He spends six weeks in custody,
and then as soon as he gets out,
he first has to go into house arrest.
He starts firing, you
know, the Jewish members
of his supervisory boards
and executive boards.
He starts removing them
from his company boards, even
though he says, you know,
he later purports himself to be a victim
of Goebbels and a victim
of the Nazi regime
and as an opponent, even though he becomes
one of the Third Reich's
largest profiteers.
And he, you know, quickly takes advantage
of business partners that he had.
There was a banker named Jacob Goldsmith,
which both Friedrich
Flick and Gunther Quandt
did a lot of business with and was,
served on their company boards.
He is by both Quandt and
Flick is swiftly removed
from his boards, from their boards.
And, you know, is forced
to flee Nazi Germany.
And that is again emblematic also
of the thinking of these men.
They are not convinced
anti-Semites, but they are,
they are willing to play
along with the Nazi regime
as long as it benefits their
companies, their fortunes,
and, you know,
they will not do anything that
goes against the rules by,
you know, going the extra mile
to save their Jewish
colleagues or employees
from persecution.
Now, following the implementation
of the Nuremberg Race Laws
in mid-September 1935,
where of course, the
disenfranchisement of Jewish citizens
in Nazi Germany really ramps up,
you see this concept of Arya,
which later became known as Aryanization,
really enter into the discourse
for German businessmen.
And the concept of
Aryanization was this idea
of the removal of the Jewish element
from the ownership of an asset,
whether that was a Jewish
owned company, shares, jewelry,
art, real estate, that's where it starts.
And of course, initially
these transactions
still have the veneer of a
regular business transaction
between I would say 1935 to 1937,
but they very soon afterwards
become the outright
expropriation and appropriation
by the Nazi regime,
as well as the businessman
I'm writing about.
I mean, I give countless
examples in my book
of Aryanization, but I will give several,
and the most prominent
one I wanna start with
is the removal of Adolf Rosenberger,
the co-founder of Porsche,
of the Porsche company
by his two,
or the buyout is the correct term
of Adolf Rosenberger by his
two Porsche company co-founders
Anton Piëch and Ferdinand Porsche.
They, the three of them start
the car design company in 1930
in Stuttgart, and they, you know,
on the day that Adolf Rosenberger
resigns in January 1933,
30th of January, 1933 is also the day
that Adolf Hitler seizes power in Germany.
He resigns, Rosenberger,
because he is fed up with being,
he's the commercial director of Porsche,
and he's fed up with, you know,
being the financial backer
of the Porsche company,
which is blowing through
money on the expensive designs
of Ferdinand Porsche, the
mercurial car designer
and whose company, you
know, it's namesake company,
but Adolf Rosenberger
has 10% of the shares.
He stays on, Adolf Rosenberger
as a Porsche shareholder
until July 1935,
when he's bought out
of the Porsche company
at the nominal value of his shares,
which was 3000 Reichsmark.
Now, at this point in
time, Ferdinand Porsche
has convinced Hitler to put
his design, the Volkswagen
into production.
While the Porsche Company
was verging on bankruptcy
on January 30th, 1933, by the
time July 1935 comes around,
it is a very profitable company.
However Adolf Rosenberger is bought out
for the nominal value of
his shares, 3000 Reichsmark,
which is far below the market
value of his actual shares.
And that is again,
and that is a stereotypical
form of Aryanization,
the way these transactions were conducted.
They wanted to remove, Piëch
and Porsche wanted to remove
Adolf Rosenberger as a shareholder,
which Adolf Rosenberger later contends
is because they wanted
to have a classification
as a company which was,
you know, free of Jews.
And, you know, Adolf Rosenberger
is ready to leave Germany.
He actually is,
then soon after he gets
bought out of Porsche
detained in a concentration camp
on the charge of racial defilement
and is helped by his successor
as commercial director
helps him to be freed from
the concentration camp.
Porsche and Piëch don't
do anything to help
their co-founder out
and later a whole legal battle ensues.
And the other families
in my book Quandt as well
greatly profits from Aryanization.
He acquires the companies of,
he acquires several battery
companies owned by German Jews
far below the market
value of their shares.
And Friedrich Flick actually
becomes the largest profiteer
of, or at least largest privately,
of the private businessman
becomes the largest profiteer
of Aryanization.
He takes over the massive
Petschek Braunkohlen Conglomerates
in central Germany in one for $6 million
also far below the market
value of the shares
of one branch of the Petschek dynasty.
And the other one is outright expropriated
by the Nazi regime.
And he ends up in a asset swap
with those Braunkohlen as well.
Another, the fourth family
I write about in the book
is August von Finck, and August von Finck,
I write about both senior and junior.
They are, is a co-founding
financiers family
of Allianz and Munich Re,
today two of the largest,
two of the world's largest
insurers and re-insurers.
And August von Finck Senior, his father,
co-founded Allianz and Munich Re.
His father dies when he's
25, and he in inherits these,
you know, the largest stakes
in these insurance companies,
as well as a controlling stake
in the family's private bank,
Merck Finck.
And Hitler asks him in 1933
because he is, you know,
as Nazi officials call him
Bavaria's wealthiest and stingiest man,
he asks him if von Finck can fundraise
as he refuses to spend any money himself,
if he can fundraise for
the house of German art,
which is Hitler's pet project,
a new museum on the Southern border
of the Englischer Garten in Munich,
and von Finck readily
says yes, and is happy to,
and ends up fundraising
20 million Reichsmark
from his fellow tycoons and
financiers for the building of,
for the building of that museum,
which today is still a
very prominent building
in Munich.
And as a thank you for his
successful fundraising efforts
von Finck is rewarded
by being allowed to Aryanize
the Rothschild Bank,
which is the Austrian branch,
which is Austria's largest private bank,
and the Austrian branch
of the Rothschild family.
And he's also allowed
to Aryanize in Berlin,
the Dreyfus Bank branch.
And he does so, he first does so by,
the museum opens in 1937,
and he uses also, you know, the code of,
the laws of Nazi Germany
in a way also of attacking
not only of Aryanizing
these private banks, which, you know,
expands his business empire significantly,
but also by attacking his
fellow private bankers,
which was greatly dominated by, you know,
there were a lot of private
banks at the time owned by Jews
who many who have been
around for generations.
He uses it, he utilizes the antisemitism
in vigorously attacking
fellow private bankers,
and so successfully that, you know,
his attacks and then his
subsequent Aryanizations
cause kind of a bank run
on other Jewish owned private banks.
And it is, you know, it becomes,
forms kind of the blueprint for the,
as they called it de-Jewification
of German's private banking system.
And August von Finck becomes
the largest profiteer
in Nazi Germany of private
banking Aryanizations.
The last example I wanna provide
of the families that I write about
is the Oetker/Kaselowsky family.
Richard Kaselowsky is
the CEO of Dr. Oetker.
a large baking goods
conglomerates, whose stepson,
who is mentoring his
stepson Rudolf August Oetker
to take over as CEO of the
Dr. Oetker pudding empire.
This is mainly a European
based conglomerate still today,
very well known for its frozen pizzas,
and it's pudding mixes.
And Richard Kaselowsky is
actually one of the few men
who is like an ideological
national socialist.
He is really convinced.
He's a convinced Nazi.
The other examples that I gave
of the other industrialists
and financiers are for the most
part, yeah, are opportunists
who, you know, leverage antisemitism
and the laws of Nazi Germany
to their business advantage.
Whereas Richard Kaselowsky
is such a convinced National
Socialist that he actually,
it's to the detriment
of Dr. Oetker's business
because they own, for instance,
they own not only a baked goods company,
but they also own a publishing company,
and they merge on
Kaselowsky's instigation,
they merge a very highly
profitable newspaper that they have
with a Nazi publication
that is bleeding money.
And his stepson Rudolf August Oetker
who ends up voluntarily
applying and joining
the Waffen-SS.
At one point, he goes to Hamburg,
he's 21 years old in 1937,
and he acquires the house
of a Jewish executive
who had fled to Australia.
And it's actually the only
time in the book where somebody
where Kaselowsky warns his
stepson, who he mentors,
he says, beware.
To this house, tears stick to this house.
I mean, I cite it in the book,
and it is quite confounding
that the only kind of sense of remorse
or a sense of forewarning
in the context of an Aryanization I found
was of somebody who was
an ideological Nazi.
He wasn't so much, again, he
wasn't, he was also a latent,
yeah, I use the word latent antisemite.
He was not a racial antisemite.
Kaselowsky also had many
Jewish business partners
who, of course, he swiftly
cut ties with following 1933,
but it is the only instance I came across
during my research and that
of the one ideological Nazi,
where he warns his stepson
of what he is about to do
with the organization that you know,
of the moral implications that there are.
Of course, his stepson,
Rudolph August Oetker
became one of Germany's most prominent
post-war industrialists, shrugs this off
and buys the house of the
fled tobacco executive
far under market value of his shares.
So these are really the
bulk of the examples
in the Aryanization period.
I wanna move over to the postwar period
where Friedrich Flick
stands on trial in 1947
in the Nuremberg trial that is led by,
it's a subsequent Nuremberg trials.
Of course, you have the
main Nuremberg trial
where 24 of Nazi Germany's
most high profile politicians
and military leaders were
indicted and convicted,
but there's, but under
the American purview,
you have 12 subsequent trials,
and the Flick trial is one of them.
Friedrich Flick is indicted and convicted
on charges of war crimes
and crimes against humanity.
And the trial is led by
the Prosecutor General,
whose name is Telford Taylor.
And he writes, or sorry,
he says in his opening statement,
"The defendants will tell you
that they were not antisemitic
"and even protected individual
Jews against the Nazis,
"yet it was not beneath them
to appear in public with,
"and pay king's ransom to Himmler,"
the SS leader Heinrich Himmler,
"who all but rendered the
Jews extinct in Europe.
"They fattened on the
misfortunes of wealthy Jews,"
et cetera, et cetera,
and Friedrich Flick in his defense says,
well, I'm actually exactly what
Telford Taylor says in his,
in his opening statement,
Friedrich Flick uses the defense.
Well, actually I was a
protector of all Jews,
even though he was the largest
profiteer of Aryanizations
in the Third Reich.
He says I protected the Jewish businessmen
whose companies I acquired.
And, you know, in order not to
have the suspicion fall on me,
I sometimes also made, you know,
a casual antisemitic remark
during the Aryanizations.
In many of the memos, you find some,
you find some of his very
offhand antisemitic remarks.
And he said, I did that in
order to not be too suspicious,
and not to have the
suspicion land on me that,
you know, I was a supporter of the Jews,
which of course is a
completely inverted reality
and perversion of reality.
I want to give two more examples.
I wanna go to the late 1970s
in which Ferry Porsche,
the son of Ferdinand Porsche
and the man who receives
Adolf Rosenberger's shares
after his father and his brother-in-law
buy Rosenberger out of the
Porsche company in 1935.
In 1976, Ferry Porsche
who designed the first Porsche sports car,
was also a voluntary SS officer,
voluntarily applied to the SS in '38,
entered the SS or was
admitted to the SS in 1941,
and ends up surrounding himself
with high ranking former SS
officers at the Porsche Company.
Of course, then a global sports
icon in the 1950s and 60s.
In 1967 in his first autobiography,
which is solely published
in the United States
by Doubleday at the time.
It's called "We at Porsche."
For the Porsche sports company,
the American market is
the most important market.
He has no trouble at all
spewing virulent antisemitic vitriol
about Adolf Rosenberger,
who he accused of extorting
him and his father
and his brother-in-law
and the Porsche Company
after the war ends.
And Rosenberger tries to get compensated
for being bought out
of the Porsche Company
for under market value of his shares.
And he writes the following.
I wanna read that part as well,
"Almost a decade after
Rosenberger's death,
"Ferry published his first
autobiography, 'We at Porsche.'
"In it, the sports car designer
not only twisted the truth
"of Rosenberger's Aryanization
and escape from Nazi Germany,
"but also did the same with the
stories of other German Jews
"who were forced to sell their firms
"and flee Hitler's regime.
"Ferry even accused Rosenberger
of extortion after the war.
"What's more the former SS officer
"used blatant antisemitic
stereotypes and prejudice
"in his warped account.
"After the war, it seemed
as though those people
"who had been persecuted by the Nazis
"considered it their right
to make an additional profit,
"even in cases where they
had already been compensated.
"Rosenberger was by no
means an isolated example,
"Ferry writes.
"Ferry, now in his mid
60s, supplied an example
"of a Jewish family
"who had voluntarily sold their factory
"after leaving Nazi Germany
for Mussolini's Italy
"only to return after
the war and claim payment
"a second time, at least
according to his interpretation
"of events.
"Ferry continued, it would be
hard to blame the Rosenberger
"for thinking in a like manner.
"He no doubt felt that since he was Jewish
"and had been forced out
of Germany by the Nazis
"who had done so much harm,
"he was entitled to an extra profit."
So that latent antisemitism that,
and this is quite explicit,
that I referred to earlier
to those patriarchs and
those industrialists
in the Weimar Republic in Nazi Germany,
this thinking for many
continued unabatedly
in the post-war era, and
in West Germany, you know,
without any seasoning.
I mean, the fact that Ferry
Porsche felt so confident
to write this down in
English, in a, you know,
very publicly, in his
very publicly published
first autobiography goes to
show how common and widespread
this, you know, casual use of
antisemitic remark, you know,
that he dared to put
it in such a, you know,
public in his first autobiography,
which was first published in English.
And only later two years
later, four years later,
published in German.
But to give an indication
of that thinking today,
I wanted to conclude on
by giving the example of
August von Finck Junior,
who is the son of August von Finck Senior.
August von Finck Junior
died this November,
November 2021 in London at the age of 91.
He became after his father died,
one of Germany's most secretive
and most successful investors and somebody
who started funding German
conservative right wing
and ultimately far right causes.
And he, and he did that
over a three decade period,
starting in the 1990s and ending
or at least to what has been
come known to the public,
ending in delayed odds around 2017.
And there is a, he worked together,
his right hand man,
a man named Ernst Knut Stahl
was kind of his money man,
and the man who would serve as a conduit
between August von Finck
Junior's political spending
and the anti-EU, anti-Euro,
libertarian, conservative,
or free market liberal
causes he would donate to.
And at one point there is a lunch,
and this happens in May of 2017 in Munich.
There is a lunch in, it happens in Munich.
There is a lunch that Ernst
Knut Stahl has with a publisher.
He's trying to recruit a publisher
for a new right wing publication
or far right publication in Germany.
And he says, reportedly
at that meeting, he says,
"There's danger ahead,
"von Finck Junior's Lieutenant said to me
"There's a street in New York
"with lots of investment
bankers, lawyers and so forth.
"Coincidentally, they're all Jews,
"but that's not relevant here.
"They want to push Germany into ruin.
"They control everything,"
says Ernst Knut Stahl during
a May 2017 meeting in,
lunch meeting in Munich.
To give you an example of how, you know,
this is a prominent businessman,
and he's the right hand man
to one of Germany's wealthiest
and most prolific political spenders
over the past couple of decades.
To give you just one
indication of unfortunately
how prevalent this thinking
and saying still is.
So I would like to
conclude it on that note.
Thank you.
I look forward to your questions.
- Okay.
Thank you so much, David.
And there's really I think
a lot to dig into here,
and I urge everybody to
please submit questions.
Again, excuse me, using the Q&A function
at the bottom of your screen.
And I will filter them to David,
but I have a lot of questions of my own.
So first of all, if you
could just start by saying,
what was your most kind
of surprising discovery
doing this research?
I imagine, you know, as
you make clear, you know,
some of this was known already,
at least in certain ways, but some wasn't.
So like what to you was your biggest find?
- I think actually the
Adolf Rosenberger storyline,
which I added latest to the book.
It was actually my
partner pointed out to me
a documentary that was
broadcast on German television
in summer of 2019,
which brings up the fact
that Adolf Rosenberger
was completely erased from
Porsche Company history.
And the fact that, you know,
Porsche, such a global icon,
such a global brand
had a Jewish co-founder
who was not only, you know, bought out
far below the market value of his shares
but was also just completely
erased from company history.
And it actually turned out, to me
that was the biggest surprise
on a kind of, on a micro level of stories.
But I think on a macro
level, on the bigger picture,
I think, and it also was the reason
why I started writing the
book in the first place
was the fact how, you know,
brazen the whitewashing today still is
by companies like Porsche and BMW,
where they have all these,
you know, global foundations
in the name of Adolf Rosen, pardon,
of Ferry Porsche and
Herbert Quandt who saved BMW
from 1959, celebrating
their business successes,
but leaving out, you
know, any part of their,
of the war crimes they committed,
or the Nazi affiliations that they had.
And, you know, after these families
and these companies
purported to have reckoned
with their Third Reich, with
their Nazi era histories
and activities.
And I think that, especially
in this day and age,
and I got this idea back in,
for the book back in 2014,
and it, you know, it didn't change.
You know, it was eight years.
I mean, they had eight years
to come clean about it, but,
you know, I, you know,
luckily for me they didn't
because, you know, I could, you know,
but I thought every day.
It's like, I thought every
day it was going to be,
it was going to be like they're going to--
- Scooped, yeah.
- Yes, exactly.
I'm gonna get scooped.
I'm gonna get front run on this news, but.
- Okay, so, you know, as I
was reading the book, I kept,
I had a running dialogue
with myself, like,
well, which are the worst?
You know, like there are.
- Yeah.
- I kept kind of going back and forth.
- Good question.
- And clearly there are kind
of varying degrees of guilt,
but I'm wondering if you had a thought
about which one you thought was the worst.
- Well, I do think that the Quandts,
or at least the two Quandt
siblings today could,
well, are you talking about the patriarchs
or the like the entire families or?
- Yeah, both, yeah.
- I mean, in terms of
patriarchs, I think they're,
I can't really distinguish.
I think they were all
equally awful in a sense,
but I do think that those families today
that control the families
like the Quandts or the BMW,
or the siblings that control BMW today,
the Quandt siblings
that control BMW today,
as well as the Porsche-Piëch clan
and the Porsche more to an
extent that control Porsche,
but not only Porsche, but
also Volkswagen, Audi, Benz,
et cetera,
and that have these
outward facing foundations
and corporate headquarters
and even media prizes
named after these men
without being transparent.
I think they are the most blatant
in the cover up of the history.
And I think also because they
control such global brands
and have such global
outward facing companies,
they also have a bigger
responsibility to be transparent
about the history, in my opinion.
- So a question from the audience,
could you say a little bit
about what conditions were like
in some of the factories
that Jews had to work
as slave laborers in?
- It's very much different.
I mean, and there were also,
there were also, for the most part Jewish
or slave labor done by Jews
who were kept in
concentration camps for their,
you know, for their,
who were not sent to
extermination camps, right.
Because that's the distinguishes
we're talking about here
at this point.
You know, they were kept
in some concentration camps
or they were deported
from concentration camps
to the factory complexes at Volkswagen
or at Gunther Quandt and Herbert
Quandt's battery factories.
And, you know, they, I mean,
they were kept in the most,
you know, there were.
I know, at Quandt's
factory outside of Hanover,
there was a gallows.
You know, there were abusive kapos
who beat prisoners sometimes to death.
I mean, it ranged.
I mean, they were
on the lowest bottom of the rung
were the Jewish slave laborers
followed by mainly Slavic
force and slave laborers,
millions who were deported
from Poland, Ukraine, Russia,
and Belarus and other
Eastern European countries.
And, you know, Western
Europeans for the most part
were comparatively treated much better.
I mean, yeah, yeah.
- I mean, which, you know,
wasn't even, you know,
pretty bad, but, yeah.
- Exactly, yes, yeah.
- So, okay, another question.
Can you give examples of big
German firms or individuals
that refused to collaborate
with the Nazi regime?
So did, you know, I
imagine some refused maybe
to actively profit from Aryanization,
but can you give any
positive examples here of?
- I mean, you have, you have,
there's the example of Robert Bosch
who was this industrial, very
well known industrialist.
And is the company that
he left behind, Bosch,
which is owned by a foundation,
not owned by family anymore.
The company he left behind, you know,
is still one of the world's,
or is a massive industrial,
pardon is a massive electro
technical conglomerate today.
And he was a very
progressive industrialist,
really took care of the labor conditions
for his employees, already
going back to the Kaiser Reich
and Weimar Republic.
And he was very much anti Hitler, and he,
but even he, even he, and he support
through his right hand
man funded the resistance
to the extent he could.
I mean, he died in 1942, Robert Bosch did.
And he, you know, but even
he mass produced weapons
for the Third Reich and used,
and forced labor was used
in his company, in his company.
So, and I would say he's
one of the, you know,
positive examples.
I mean, you know, that's
the most positive example
I can give.
Across the board, forced, and
to a lesser extent slave labor
was used by German business.
- Yeah.
- And Aryanizations, you
know, Aryanizations occurred,
you know, this was a
business decision, right.
This was a,
so it occurred only if they made sense.
You know, these businessmen didn't make
Aryanization acquisitions
if it didn't make sense
for their business expansion.
So these were all,
these were all business
deliberations that they made.
Does this asset make sense?
Can we get it for the right price?
These were cold, calculating decisions.
- Yeah.
- So, so for instance,
mass conglomerates who
didn't do any Aryanizations,
it doesn't mean that, you know,
that that says something about
that they were any better
than Gunther Quandt or
Friedrich Flick who did.
It was just that it didn't make sense,
such acquisitions didn't
make sense in their overall,
I mean, in their M&A strategy,
in their corporate development
strategy, you know.
- Okay, I'm feeling a little
bit better about my dishwasher,
but a little bit worse
about my coffee maker.
You know, so question
about what the allies did
to push for punishment
of these, you know, firms
or wealthy Germans after the war.
Was there any effort of the
occupying allied, you know,
as part of the de-Nazification process?
- I mean, it starts
with initially it starts
with the Morgenthau Plan.
Robert Morgenthau Jr. was
the Treasury Secretary,
proposes the Morgenthau Plan,
which basically called
for the entire dismantling
of Germans' industry and
the summarily execution,
not just the political
and military leaders,
but also of business leaders.
That plan is scrapped.
And instead you have this
plan that is mainly drawn up
by John J. McCloy and his boss
Stinson in the War Department
who, you know, also, you know,
we could talk about the
antisemitism of German big business,
but of course it was rife in
the American State Department
and War Department too.
And they come up with this plan
which envisions the Nuremberg trials,
oversees the occupation and the dividing
of an occupied Germany
between the United States
and the United Kingdom,
and also oversees the,
as they called it,
which was part of the four Ds,
de-Nazification was one of them,
but so was decartelization
and deconcentration
of German industry,
which in the end does not really,
it doesn't really happen
to a large extent.
It's only, IG Farben is
a very prominent example
of at the time the largest chemicals
and pharmaceuticals conglomerate
in the world split up
in what is today, BASF and Bayer,
still two of the large
companies in the world
in pharmaceuticals and
chemicals, respectively.
But for the most part, of
course, the cold war emerges,
and, you know, initially Harry Truman
and then Ike Eisenhower,
but particularly Truman
makes the policy decision
that we, that United States government
needs a viable democratic,
or economically viable and
democratic West Germany
as a bulwark against an
encroaching Soviet Union,
and all the aspirations
and ambitions that they had
for the reform of German
society and de-Nazification,
it all quickly goes out the window,
and the aim, the overarching
aim becomes the build up
of West German society
as a democratic and a
capitalist state, yeah.
- So some people are asking, you know,
you really focus on kind of
heavy industry, I would say,
in the book, but, you know,
you clearly could have talked
about, you know, some people,
someone raised the question
of like the entertainment
business, you know,
and I imagine that there
were kind of similar stories
going on in all different
aspects of, you know,
all different areas of the German economy.
Is that true would you say, or?
- Well, listen, I mean,
I picked the families,
I picked the business families of those
that are still most
relevant today in European,
in German, European and global business,
so that it could have, you know,
I think in a sense the
businesses that I chose,
and I think that's why
they're also so emblematic
or so exemplary of the larger,
wider business community
and their thoughts is
because they do range.
I mean sure, Gunther Quandt,
Friedrich Flick, big industry,
but one would say, you know, Porsche car,
and then of course the,
von Finck is in finance
and the Oetkers are in
consumer goods at that time.
- Yeah.
- Right, so it does, it does give,
the two main characters are
indeed in heavy industry,
but I wanted to focus on those families
that are relevant today, so what,
regardless of what industries
they were in at the time
of the Nazi era.
- Yeah, and I, you know,
your opening kind of scene
where these rich Germans are summoned
to a meeting with Hitler
is incredibly chilling
where like you want, you know,
there's a lot, you know,
how are they gonna react?
And they, you know,
are more than willing to help finance his.
So here, a bunch of people have, you know,
put forward a really interesting
question that I had too,
which is, you know, you end the
book on a maybe hopeful note
saying, you know, we will do better.
- Right.
- But a lot of people are asking
what that would look like.
So what do you hope
your book accomplishes?
What kind of reckoning are
you hoping for with this book?
- I mean, at the bare minimum is this,
and that's also the idea I went into.
I mean the book is an argument
in favor of historical transparency.
And I think at the bare minimum,
these families should be
with the massive consumer
brands that they control
should be outwardly
transparent about the histories
of the vaunted patriarchs
that they called their foundations
and global headquarters
and brands and media prizes after.
I mean, I think that is a bare
minimum that we can expect.
And if they don't wanna
do that, then, you know,
I think they should rename.
They should rename.
That is what a reckoning,
that is what an honest and
transparent reckoning looks like
to me, because I also think, you know,
one learns from history by
showing the good and the bad.
And if you just celebrate
somebody's business success,
but leave out their war crimes,
especially today, when we live
in an age of such, you know,
disinformation all across
the board, you know,
these families particularly
have a responsibility,
not only to the consumers,
but also to history
to be transparent about it.
- And, you know, you cite,
I forget which one it was,
but like a young woman now who
just recently gave a speech
that where she's just completely,
it's not even like they're
trying to hide it anymore.
I mean, she's almost like,
you know, like the past,
what does it matter?
I'm rich.
- Yeah.
- So I, you know, and.
- It's very troubling,
which is a very troubling indication
for where Germany is headed.
- Yeah.
- She spoke, she spoke off
the cuff, but, you know,
I mean kind of the blatant lack
of any historical knowledge
and kind of any sense of morality
that Verena Bahlsen displayed,
not only during that speech,
but particularly in the follow
up comments that she gave
to build the German--
- Right, it's a food company.
Like they have a.
- It's Bahlsen, Bahlsen,
it's a very famous.
- Bahlsen, yeah.
But there was some shaming
and kind of boycotting
it seemed like after
her speech, so there's.
- Sure, and I saw,
I end the book all the way in the back
in the notes of sources,
where she gives this
interview in September, 2021
to the Deutsche Society
about how, you know,
she now forces her
family to talk about it.
And therefore she's forcing them
to be more transparent about
it, but it's still difficult.
So, I mean, I do, I am, I mean,
to get back to the previous
question, you know,
I am hopeful about my generation,
even though some show,
you know, a blatant lack of
knowledge about that period,
you know, particularly those German,
and particularly those who
are end up being the heirs.
Because I do think in
the four and a half years
that I lived in Germany and
I know that in the op-ed too,
in the essay too, in the
New York Times is that I,
everybody is extremely aware
and is extremely reflective and is trying
to make a better Germany, you know?
And of course with its
political and economic might,
you know, is extremely important.
- Yeah, I mean,
one of the kind of fascinating
things is you described
that many of these families
have hired historians
to uncover the truth about their past,
but somehow these histories wind up
almost seeming like part of
the cover up in some ways.
I mean, they're kind.
- Yes, unintentionally, in
some cases, in most cases,
completely unintentionally
and in some intentionally.
- Yeah, I mean, you
said they were actually
kind of good historians often,
but then the book comes out,
and they think they've done
everything they need to do,
and then nobody, you know.
- The historians and
their research, I mean,
it's also insulting to the
historians and their researchers
will work on this project
for three, four years.
And then these studies come out,
and they are only published
in dense academic German,
and then, you know, nothing changes.
And then the findings,
you can't find anywhere
except in like a 1,200 page
study in dense academic German.
And then it also begs the question
who then exactly is this
reckoning with, right?
Because for the most part,
the Germans of course,
were not the victims of the
crimes of these patriarchs,
and their businesses.
- Right.
- So, but, you know, surviving
forced and slave laborers
and their heirs never get
any access to these details.
- Yeah.
- So it very much begs the
question, you know, and then,
you know, when a company
or a family, again,
doesn't do anything, you know,
just goes to show that they don't, to me,
it goes to show that it's not an honest
and transparent reckoning
that they've initiated.
- So your book is about
to come out in German also
which is, you know, fascinating.
So what do you imagine
the reaction is gonna be?
You're gonna do a whole, you
know, book tour there you said.
Like have you gotten any advance
sense of what the reaction?
- No, no, I haven't.
No, no, I mean, the
book is gonna come out.
The German translation is
gonna come out May 5th.
I mean the two translators
and the editor and myself
worked extremely hard on
the German translation
to be the best version
it, I mean, you know,
the English language
version is also great,
but the even better version of that one,
and, you know, we really
worked on it day and night,
particularly in January, December,
January, and early March.
And, you know, I got a sense,
actually the man who
inspired me to write the book
or gave me the idea for the book
is a German journalist who
wrote biographies on the Quandts
and the Oetkers, and he
actually I'd sent him a,
I'd send him a, yeah, an
advanced copy of the book,
and he say, I woke up to this
morning with a note from him
that he said he read it in one go.
And he said, I learned a lot.
And it's really well read,
and really well told and
et cetera, et cetera.
So that's, I mean, in a way,
he's my most important critic
since he inspired me to write
the book back in 2012, 2013,
or gave me the idea that I
should write about this topic
in a way, not explicitly,
but through the interviews
I had with him at the time,
I got the idea and, you know,
in a way he's my most important critic.
So the fact that he approved
of it already goes to show,
I'm almost already very happy.
- Yeah, that's fantastic.
Okay, well, we're out of time,
but I wanna say thank you so much
for sharing your research
and telling us about
this really important chapter in history.
I wanna thank everyone in
the audience for coming.
I wanna urge you all to please sign up
to be on the YPSA mailing list.
This is our last talk for this year,
but we'll have many important
lectures next year too.
And please join me in
thanking David de Jong
for that great presentation today.
- Thank you, Maurie.
It was my pleasure.
It was really nice to be here.
- And good luck with.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
- Yeah, okay.
Bye, everybody.